[Music]
NK jamson's short story the ones who
stay in fight found in how long till
black future month is clearly and
deliberately a response to a classic
short story by Ursula K Len the ones who
walk away from
and she tells us that in the very
introduction she says that the ones who
stay in fight is a pasti of in reaction
to leen's story and then in uh a very
important interview in Paris review
she's going to tell us that the city
umot is really a response to that city
of omus that is going to also come up
within the story itself where she says
this is umh halot after all and not that
barbaric America so there's a contrast
between our mode of living and the mode
of living uh narrated in this story and
then she says this is not olalus a tick
of a city fat and happy with its head
buried in a tortured child and if you
don't know Ursa K leen's story there is
this Utopian city omus and she's
narrating a festival that takes place
and the coming of age that each of the
citizens of alalas have to go through
where they are brought to see a uh
damaged essentially tortured child who
will never understand the reason for its
suffering just one and its suffering
cannot be alleviated and they are told
that this is the price of the beauty the
harmony the way of life that they enjoy
and
um gemson is going to call this in that
interview Len's gut punch and she says
this is actually something great about
the story Len confronts us with an
allegory for according to gemson the
capitalist society that we live in where
no matter what we whatever Joy whatever
happiness whatever uh security we have
is predicated on exploiting somebody on
somebody else's suffering right and so
some people could leave olalus and
perhaps start their own Society
elsewhere or as she says live off the
grid and gemson is going to reject that
and say what we want to think about is
what a true Utopia would actually look
like a society that's truly
inclusive
egalitarian good for all people can we
have a society that not only removes the
negative the traces of violence of
irrational discrimination of
exploitation of Cruelty of suffering or
alleviate you know at least alleviate
suffering can we have that and can we go
beyond that to something that is truly
joyous and not necessarily Blissful but
meaningful
and so that is where we begin with this
Festival that she's narrating and using
essentially as a background and
likeus is this really a short story or
is this more of an essay well it's set
in a narrative
framework and there is a story going on
within it but it's a story that's WR
large telling us about the nature of
this society and we we do also have the
narration of how wonderful this Festival
is and we get to see depicted what kind
of a city this is like so what is umot
it is a city of Joy Of Happiness of care
of love these positive terms are used
over and over again here's one beautiful
Line This is no awkward dystopia where
all are forced to conform adults who
refuse to give up their childhood Joys
wear wings too and theirs tend to be
more abstractly constructed the children
wear Wings right and she says um they
are honored for this Choice even those
who don't wear Wings don't want wings
whose Faith forbid the emulation of
beasts they're honored for this choice
for without contrast how does one
appreciate the different forms that Joy
can take myriad
possibilities of joy for all of the
different people and she goes on and she
says oh and there is such Joy here
friend she gives example Street vendors
sell tiny custard filed cakes shaped
like Jewel beetles and people who have
waited all year wolf them down while
sucking air to cool their tongues
Artisans offer cleverly mechanized paper
hummingbirds for passerbys to throw the
best one blur as they Glide as the day
goes long umot farmers are arrive
invited as always to be honored among
the city's merchants and
technologes by all three efforts does
the city Prosper here in umhat there's
no hunger not among the people and not
even for the migrating birds and
butterflies and they talk about these
encounters that people have with each
other a man who's somewhat embarrassed
about the ladybug that he's made and a
woman sees it and smiles and makes much
of it she points and others see it too
which makes him blush but there is only
kindness and genuine pleasure in the
smiles and gradually the reading man
stands a little taller walks with a
wider
stride he has made his fellow citizens
happier and there is no finer virtue by
the customs of this gentle rich land
isn't that a a beautiful vignette to
illustrate in narrative this principle
she goes on and she says joyous it is a
steady joy that fills this city easy to
speak of but most difficult to describe
accurately and then she's going to talk
to her interloc who will mention in a
bit and says I can see the incredulity
in your face thinking about this kind of
Joy she goes on and says this is umh
halot a city whose inhabitants simply
care for one another other that is a
city's purpose they believe not merely
to generate revenue or energy or
products but to shelter and nurture the
people who do these things we should
pause for a moment and think about that
line This is a city's purpose this takes
us all the way back to ancient political
philosophy where Aristotle could say
that the reason we have a polus a
political Community a city is not just
to live not to manufacture things but to
live well to Zay now of course the city
that Aristotle spent much of his life in
as an outof toer literally a non-citizen
was a city based on slavery and many
different forms of
exploitation right but there's a
glimmering of that and in umh halot this
is a city where people are trying to
live well and what does that include joy
happiness care love these positive
things they're
also Smart in a way that we often aren't
there's a kind of prudence here right um
she says what what have I forgot to
mention it's the thing that will seem
most fantastic to you friend the variety
the citizens of umh halad are so many
and wildly different in appearance and
origin and development and she goes down
and says um there are differences
between people there are darker people
doing more menial trades but they're
trying to correct this why because the
people of umh halad are not naive
Believers in Good Intentions as the
solution of all ills there are no
worshippers of mere tolerance here nor
desperate gravers for that grudging
pittance of respect which is diversity
um Hans are learned enough to understand
what must be done to make the world
better
and pragmatic enough to actually enact
it and now we get to this interloc right
her angry interlocutor first incredulous
and then getting
upset with her uh she goes on and she
says does this seem wrong to you it
shouldn't the trouble is we have a bad
habit encouraged by those concealing ill
content of insisting people already
suffering should be afflicted with
further un necessary pain and then she's
going to say something that's going to
show up a little bit later in these
social workers that's the Paradox of
Tolerance the treason of free speech we
hesitate to admit that some people are
just evil and need to be stopped that is
part of this being pragmatic enough to
do what is going to make a good Society
to oppose evil to stay and fight now the
interloc becomes angry with her right
um she goes on how does umh halad exist
how can a city possibly survive let
alone Thrive and then she puts words in
interlocker mouth it can't be you say
Utopia how Bal it's a fairy tale a
thought exercise crabs in a barrel Doggy
Dog oppression Olympics it would not
last you insist it could never be in the
first place Place racism is natural so
natural we will call it tribalism to
insinuate that everybody does it sexism
is natural and homophobia is natural and
religious intolerance is natural and
greed is natural and cruelty is natural
and savagery and fear and and impossible
you hiss your fists slowly crunching
clenching at your sides how dare
you what have these people done to make
you believe such Li eyes what are you
doing to me to suggest that it is
possible this is the response that many
people have to suggesting that something
like this could be
possible possible not just in the sense
of an
afterlife or a mere imagined uh Utopia
she says a thought experiment but that
our world could be transformed to be
something like this and she
says how else can I convey this to you
when even the thought of a happy and
just
society makes you angry a city like this
you're saying goes against
nature goes against how human beings are
and she says it's almost as if you feel
threatened by the very idea of
equality people being genuinely equal it
almost as if some part of you needs to
be angry need needs unhappiness and
Injustice and then says is that really
the case do you need this what's going
on with you that you actually do need
this and this is a suggestion to the
rest of us as well do we need something
like that not only do we in inhabit a
world in which inevitably we end up
hurting other people but does that stem
from a need deep within us that makes us
unwilling to think of a better place now
we get to these characters that she
calls something like social workers so
think of them as that if you like their
role is no different that from that of
social workers anywhere word is come of
a troubling case and this is why they
gather to discuss it and make a
difficult
decision why well because umh halot um
is actually able to receive signals from
another world now the only world that
they actually can get is our world and
so as she goes on she says that um you
know we can't travel to this they
wouldn't travel to it anyway but they
can actually uh listen on equipment
which records minute Quantum
perturbations excited by signal
wavelengths to our radio you can watch
our television you can follow our social
media play our videos like our selfies
we're remarkably primitive compared to
umh halot time flows the same in both
worlds but they have not wasted
themselves on crushing one another into
submission and that makes a remarkable
difference anyone can do it build a
thing to Traverse the world at least in
terms of
information what does this do well these
social workers are there as she says to
ensure the happiness and prosperity of
their fellow citizens
and how do they do this the people who
in fact go
between in in this way um wind up
corrupting themselves and could be
corrupting the society itself as she she
she writes um there's an entire
underground industry and umh halot crime
built around information gleaned from
the strange alien world that is our own
pamp are written and distributed art and
whispers are traded The Forbidden is
seductive is it not even here were only
things that cause harm to others are
called evil the information Gleaners
know what they do is wrong they know
what destroyed the old cities in this
world before and this is something that
all the umh halot citizens when they
reach a certain age have to learn about
and it's it's foreign to them what is
foreign for example
the young citizens of umh halot are
shocked by the realization that once
differences of opinion involve
differences in respect that once value
was ascribed to some people and not
others that once Humanity was
acknowledged for some and not
others that some people were dehumanized
that some people
were treated with contempt as she
mentions difference could lead to
contempt but difference was never the
problem in and of
itself instead it's what we do with that
difference and so these social workers
what do they do they root out the
sickness the
evil um of sharing these ideas the
contagion as we call it and going on
with
this these people are not like through
and through evil but they become
contaminated with it poisoned by it
right they begin to perceive our that
ours is a world where the notion that
some people are less important than
others has been allowed to take root and
grow until it buckles and cracks the
foundations of our Humanity how could
they these people exclaim of us us
earthers why would they do such things
how can they leave those people to
starve why do they not listen when that
one complains of disrespect what does it
mean that these ones have been assaulted
and no one no one cares who treats other
people like that they're
shocked but even in midst their shock
they share the evil the evil spreads
allowing these ideas into full
circulation will inevitably lead to
people behaving in that way and um halot
will come to resemble its own past and
our present and so what do we find mind
the social workers kill this man they
kill him painlessly quickly but he has a
daughter a daughter who sees him stabbed
through the heart with a pike and this
daughter is also herself deeply
contaminated she says I'll get back at
you I'll make you die the way you made
him die something is very wrong here she
snars how dare you how dare you much
like the angry interlocutor right the
social workers exchange looks of concern
now notice what she says here they are
contaminated themselves of course it's
permitted and frankly unavoidable in
their line of work the social workers
know that for incomprehensible reasons
this girl's father has shared the poison
knowledge of our world with her an
uncontaminated citizen would have asked
why after the initial shock and horror
because they expect a reason there would
be a reason but this girl has already
decided the social workers are less
important than her father and therefore
the reason doesn't matter she believes
the entire city is less important than
one man's selfishness poor child she is
nearly septic with the taint of our
Earthly
world but they take her and they put her
into a
quarantine and like it says there's only
one treatment for this toxin once it
gets into the blood fighting it tooth
and nail Spear and Claw up close and
brutal No Quarter can be given no parole
no debate the child must grow and learn
and become another social worker
fighting an endless war against an idea
but she will live and help others and
Find meaning in that if there's a choice
to be made here if she takes the woman's
hand and then talking back to the
interlocutor gemson says uh does this
work for you at last friend you person
who wants wants to reject this Utopia
does the possibility of harsh
enforcement add enough realism are you
better able to accept this postcolonial
Utopia now that you see its bloody
teeth but they didn't choose this battle
their ancestors did when they spun lies
and ignored conscience in order to
profit from another's pain their greed
became a philosopher a religion a series
of Nations all built on blood umad has
chosen to be better but it too must
perform blood sacrif ice to keep true
evil at Bay a
Utopia still requires sacrifice Utopia
still
requires
opposition but there's a lot of scope
for all of these great things there and
then she closes with something very
interesting where the contamination can
go a different
way so these citizens of umh halot who
have to be either killed or become
social workers are contaminated by
learning of our
world a similar thing can happen as we
learn about theirs as we read and think
about this story she says see what I've
done so Insidious these little thoughts
going both ways along the quantum path
perhaps you will think of umh halot
and wish desire right now you will find
finally be able to Envision a world
where where people have learned to love
as they learned in our world to hate
perhaps you will speak of umala to
others and spread the notion farther
still it's possible everyone even the
poor the lazy the undesirable can matter
do you see how just this idea of this
provokes utter rage and some that's
infection defending itself because if
enough of us believe a thing is possible
then it becomes so it becomes possible
not yet actual but it becomes an option
for us and so this story
itself could have a kind of
contaminating effect could it not
utopian literature isn't just Castles in
the Sky so to speak or a city in the sky
it's something that can change the way
that you and I approach each other and
other people and are
future
possibilities